it was the best day ever that's what
amazon
founder jeff bezos said after he
returned from his
rather quick trip to space he may not
have been the first billionaire to leave
the earth's atmosphere but he did
make history nonetheless exactly 52
years
after the first moon landing the new
shepherd named after america's first
astronaut alan shepard
took the first all civilian crew to the
edge of space
command engine start two one
the world's richest man hurtling towards
space
jeff bezos's blue origin space tourism
company
made its first manned flight with the
owner on board
also on board bezos's brother mark a
dutch high school student
and veteran female pilot wally funk the
youngest and oldest people
ever to leave the earth's atmosphere
[Applause]
cheers over the intercom as the voyagers
cross the line
into space and there we go our
astronauts have passed the carmen line
at about 328 thousand feet
the group were then able to unfasten
their seat belts and enjoy a few minutes
of weightlessness
[Music]
the trip lasted just over 10 minutes
before the capsule hit the texan dust
and touchdown bezos emerged
beaming
[Applause]
he later tried to describe the
experience at a press conference
[Music]
you know now on how it felt oh my god
my expectations were high and they were
dramatically exceeded
family and the
the four of us we had a great time it
was it was wonderful
i want to go again fast that excitement
could be contagious and
lucrative experts say the nascent
industry could be worth 3 billion
annually within 10 years worth popping
the champagne
joining us now for more is mark
mccochran he's a senior advisor for
science and exploration at the european
space agency
so this trip is loaded as historic
well is it really well look
anytime anybody not sits themselves on
the top of a rocket or anything that's
like a rocket and goes up to that
altitude and comes down safely is
something to
you know uh be very thankful for and in
particular i think for the science
community and the space community to see
wally funk
uh you know almost 50 years after she
was in the mercury 13 program and passed
over because she was a woman
finally making it across their
boundaries so in that sense that's
historic
um but of course it's the sort of thing
we've been doing in space since the
1960s alan shepard
for who the new shepherd rocket has
launched uh named for he flew into space
in exactly the same way essentially in
1961
so in that sense i wouldn't call it
historic we're doing things we've done
before but
it's an interesting day uh in the space
community so
what do we need this so-called space
tourism for this this little hop which
is on your first test uh
so what what will it bring to the
scientific community what will do good
for the rest of us
well i think we need to be very clear
that these suborbital hops are very
different of course to what we do with
our astronauts what nasa does which
the russians do and the chinese which is
send astronauts into orbit that requires
a huge amount more energy
and is more dangerous because of that
and then they can go to the
international space station and do
science
on these very short flights a few
minutes of
microgravity in free fall there are some
science experiments you can do there but
it's really about the tourism
aspect but there's this phrase often
used about democratization of space and
that's something which i do chafe
against a bit because
our astronauts are democratically chosen
on the basis of their skills and their
talents not on the basis of how much
money they have and i think there's some
something very symbolic we're seeing two
of the richard's men in the world
having a bit of a contest to go and do
these flights and i think that's
something very different to what perhaps
many of us
hoped space would become over the last
50 years
well this this uh billionaire space race
does remind me a little about the
uh who could build the highest
skyscraper in new york and
at least that gave us i don't know the
empire state building and the chrysler
building what will be the legacy of this
thing
well that's hard to tell i mean many
people would say this is a moment where
if you don't build that technology you
can't then make it uh broader and apply
it to other people
but i think again we need to be very
clear this is the richest man in the
world who's made a lot of money during
the coronavirus crisis because we've all
been at home buying boxes full of his
stuff
which is great but you know is that
really the way we want
civil society to go again we've got an
astronaut in space at the moment
tomorrow pesky doing science
uh we've we're just in the process of
recruiting new astronauts the european
space agency so whether this will become
a diversion or really an opening of a
gateway
into something uh much bigger for the
whole of humankind i think really the
jury's out on that at this time
mark mccochran from the european space
agency thank you
very much for your insight